Yahweh alone is the creator and and and
God. That's what it says. You alone are
Yahweh. No one else.
>> So Yahweh is the father.
>> Yahweh theology.
>> Yahweh is the father, the son, and the
spirit.
>> Okay. So you believe that they're three
separate entities.
>> Three distinct persons, not separate.
They're distinct, not separate.
>> Okay. Like would it be equivocal to me
and you? We're different people.
>> We are, but we're also separate. We're
separate human beings.
>> Okay. But they're they're like it'd be
like if me and you had our bodies, but
like we knew the same.
>> So listen, bro, I want to be honest with
you, right? I'm not a Trinitarian, but
that's also because I'm not entirely
Christian. So I just want you to make
sense of it to me, right? Is that okay?
>> Sure, I could try.
>> All right. So I wrote a paper about this
uh in like a debate class, right? And so
my my main concern with the trinity is I
know you talked about this earlier but I
kind of was like half listening right is
three entities right and I and I'm
Muslim right
>> okay
>> under under Islamic theology I'm
considered Catholic because I don't pray
consistently more but like that's the
framework
>> you said you're considered what oh
you're
>> because I don't pray consistently
anymore so under Islamic framework but
like that's that's the ideology I'm
coming off of right
>> okay
>> so I I can subscribe that all powerful
God can create three beings, but I can't
subscribe to the fact that those three
beings do not share the same conscience.
So like when we see verses like when
Jesus says he doesn't know the hour only
the father does, that to me seems like
separate because to me what oneness
entails is everything like memories, all
that all that cool stuff, you know?
>> Yeah. So number one, the trinity is not
the idea that God creates other beings.
cuz then they wouldn't be God obviously
if they're created.
>> Right.
>> So, so the trinity is that the father,
son, and spirit. They are one being.
>> Okay.
>> One eternal infinite being.
>> So when was the inception of the holy
spirit? Cuz I asked my Christian friend
and he couldn't provide like a a date.
And also Jesus has a birth.
>> Jesus has a human birth but he existed
before his human birth. And the holy
spirit has all the holy spirit has also
always been there. Can you provide how
Jesus was like eternal?
>> Yeah. So Jesus is identified as the
word. Okay.
>> Of God who was there in the beginning
>> with God and therefore
is eternal.
>> So we got John 1 1 and 3,
>> right?
>> In the beginning was the word.
>> The word was with God and the word was
God.
>> Okay. He was in the beginning with God.
So obviously there's another person
who's identified as God that he's with.
>> Okay. So Jesus was the word is what
you're trying to get at.
>> Yep. Jesus is the word.
>> So
>> watch what it says though.
>> Okay.
>> He was in the beginning with God. He was
already there.
>> Right.
>> All things came into being through him.
>> Okay.
>> And apart from him, nothing came into
being that has come into being.
>> Okay. So he in the beginning with God,
all things came into being through him
and apart from him.
>> So Okay. So can we Cool. Cool. Right. I
I'll I'll grant it. Can we come to an
agreement? What What is God? Like by
definition, what is God?
>> Uh the necessary being, the uncaused
cause of all things.
>> No, but like okay, I'm five. You're
telling me what is God? Like you open if
you open up a dictionary like what
constitutes a God?
>> Why am I not a God? Why are you not a
God?
>> Well, God is the eternal infinite being
who created all things.
>> Okay. So, can we agree that Jesus has
shown to lack god-like capabilities?
>> No.
>> He died
>> in his human flesh.
>> But he was he was bounded by human
limitations.
>> Wouldn't that make him limited? Would
that make him not godly?
>> No. This would be this is this is him
humbling himself to human limitations.
Not that he's necessarily bound to them.
So like like for example you have you
have Jesus who yeah he died in his flesh
but he says this he says
>> no one can take my life from me.
>> Right. Right. Right. Right.
>> He says
>> I lay my my life down and I and I take
it back up again.
>> Yeah.
>> Is that humanike qualities or is that
godlike qualities?
>> That's I can't do that.
>> I cannot do that.
>> Me either.
>> No. Listen. I'm I'm sorry for smiling.
It's just like I see you on YouTube and
Tik Tok and stuff so it's like wow. Like
I'm like it's kind of like a little bit.
Yeah. It's all good, bro.
>> Yeah. Like I started debate with Islamic
Apex. I'm like, you know, it's it's
interesting stuff. It's interesting
stuff.
>> Yeah.
>> So, so yeah. So, so Jesus, he he he
demonstrates how yeah, he's in human
flesh and yeah, he's in human form and
yet he humbles himself, but don't get it
twisted, he's still God in the flesh.
>> Yeah. So, right, my thing is like when
he when he said only the father knows
the hour, wouldn't this imply separation
between the two beings? I can understand
why you would say that but no because
because he's not talking about knowledge
in the sense of cognitive information.
He's talking about declarative
knowledge.
>> Wait. Okay. So not but what is knowledge
if it's not cognitive information?
>> It's declarative like things that you
make known to others. So for example,
I'll show you the same thing. Uh Paul
uses the same Greek word that that Jesus
uses there. the Greek word oid which
also means like to tell something or to
make something known right
>> so um we go to 1 Corinthians chapter 2
>> okay we look at verse 1 and two I'll put
on the screen here it is so he says and
when I came to you brothers I did not
come with superiority of word or of
wisdom proclaiming to you the witness of
God
>> so he's like I didn't come with you like
special speech I wasn't super smart
nothing like that but watch what he says
for I determined to know nothing to know
nothing
>> right
>> among you except
Jesus Christ and him crucified.
>> Right. Right.
>> So hold on. Wait one more time. Let me
read that for me one more time, please.
>> Yeah. For I determined to know nothing
among you except Jesus Christ and him
crucified.
>> So what would
>> this mean? Would this mean that Paul
doesn't know anything? No. Would this
mean that Paul doesn't know anything
else other than Christ and him
crucified? uh I would have be able to
tell you for like
>> so yeah look so look at the context he
says
>> okay
>> when I came when I came to you
>> uh
>> I I did not come with superiority of
word or of wisdom meaning I didn't come
like with special speech
>> right
>> like I didn't come with special speech
or super wisdom
proclaiming to you the witness of God so
he came to them this is what he's doing
he's proclaiming the witness of God
which is the gospel obviously right he's
coming with the message of god he didn't
come with superior language and super
wisdom. It didn't come like that when he
was proclaiming the witness of God. But
what did he do? I determined to know
nothing among you except Jesus Christ
and him crucified.
>> Okay,
>> it means that he only came declaring and
making known to them Jesus and him
crucified.
>> So this would imply that Jesus just
withheld the information from his
people.
>> Yes, he withheld information from them.
Um it's not for them to know.
>> Okay. And then and that's what he says.
He he
>> hold up. I'm sorry, brother. Uh would it
be possible for me to screen share cuz I
kind of forgot my paper, but I want to
It was actually a really I actually put
a lot of effort into it. You mind if I
just show it to you real quick? Like
could I screen share? Would that be
possible or no?
>> Screen share your paper
>> like cuz uh there's a section I wanted
to highlight. It was like, so I saw this
video by this Australian church and they
was talking about how the Trinity isn't
historically backed and it was like
apparent like can I just show you? Is
there a way I could do that or or could
I just exit out? Not ex like
>> you you can I don't you're on your phone
it looks like. Right.
>> I'm on my phone. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
>> Um I'm I don't think you can share your
screen on your phone. Am I
>> Would I would I be muted if I were to go
into a different app?
>> Yeah, I won't be able to hear you.
>> Damn. Hold up. Let me see. No. Okay. So,
basically it said that the original
Hebrew manuscripts do not uh find a
trinity. Is it okay if we were to give
me like 10 15 seconds to go look at my
paper and like get like the verbatim?
>> That's that's fine. But that's brother I
I I I don't I don't care about that
because that's that's obviously false. I
can just show you the trinity in the
Bible in the Old Testament in the
Hebrew.
>> Go ahead. Go ahead.
>> Yeah. So like like that's silly. Um
Okay. Let's do this.
>> Okay. Let's do Nehemiah. Nehemiah 9
verse 6.
>> Wait, Nehemiah is in Jeremiah.
>> No, Nehemiah is in Nehemiah was like the
Greek word for Jeremiah or something.
>> No, Nehemiah. You got Nehemiah and you
got Jeremiah.
>> Okay. Okay. Okay.
>> So, look how it says here. It says, "You
alone are Yahweh. You made the heavens,
the heaven of heavens with all their
hosts, the earth and all that's on it,
the seas and all that's in them. You
give life to all of them and the
heavenly host bows down to you.
>> Right? So Yahweh alone is the creator
and the and and God. That's what it
says. You alone are Yahweh. No one else.
>> So Yahweh is the father.
>> Yahweh theology.
>> Yahweh is the father, the son, and the
spirit.
>> Okay. So you believe that they're three
separate entities.
>> Three distinct persons, not separate.
They're distinct, not separate.
>> Okay. Like
>> would it be would it be equivalical to
me and you? We're different people.
>> We are, but we're also separate. We're
separate human beings.
>> Okay. But they're they're like it'd be
like if me and you had our bodies, but
like we knew the same or the same
like we're both us like or no.
>> So like you I I don't know what you're
asking.
>> Like Okay. Like could you try to
rationalize three different physical
bodies or three physical beings all
sharing one like essence like
>> Yeah. So so no because when you're
talking about being a being is is like
essence nature being they're kind of
synonymous right or interchangeable. Um
so when when we say being or essence
we're talking about what you are right
your your nature your makeup right so
like you are a human being
>> when I'm talking about God he is a
divine being
>> okay
>> right and so with uh human beings
there's only one p human person right
being and personhood are two different
things would you agree all let me ask
you this a rock you would agree that a
rock is a being right a rock a rock
exists and exists
>> but would You say a rock is a person.
>> Yeah. Okay. So like personhood is like
my conscience but my body is my being.
Okay. Okay. Okay. Okay. Okay.
>> Yep. Your rationale. Okay. So every
human being has one human person,
>> right? You with me?
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. My phone. My phone. My
mom texted me on my phone. My phone. My
phone. So each human being is one human
person. What we're saying about the
divine being is that there's three
divine persons. Okay. So Yahweh is three
divine person. You have Yahweh the
father, Yahweh the son, and Yahweh the
holy spirit.
>> Okay,
>> but here it says you alone. Whoops,
sorry. Says you you alone are Yahweh.
Referring to the the Yahweh as one
being, one creator. So one being,
there's one Yahweh essence-wise. Yet I'm
going to show you that there's three
distinct persons who are identified as
Yahweh. You have the father who's
identified as Yahweh. You have the son,
and you have the spirit.
>> Okay? So watch. So Yah Yahweh is just a
title.
>> Yahweh is the personal name of God. And
so but Yahweh is not univocal. So Yahweh
can refer to the essence of God or
Yahweh can be referring to any of the
persons by name. Okay. So we got
Deuteronomy 32:6 and we got uh Exodus 3.
Let's do um let's do let's do 2 to 14.
And then we have 2 Samuel 23. two to
three. All right, so remember you alone
are Yahweh, right? Nobody else. Watch
this. Does this is Deuteronomy 32:6. Do
you thus repay Yahweh, oh people who are
wickedly foolish and without wisdom? Is
he not your father who has brought you?
He has made you and established you. So
we see here, the father is Yahweh.
Right.
>> Right.
>> We go down here. Watch this. It says in
Exodus 3, this is the burning bush
story. And the angel of Yahweh appeared
to him to Moses in a blazing fire from
the midst of the bush. And he looked,
and behold, the bush was burning, but uh
with fire, yet the bush was not
consumed. So, who is it that appeared to
Moses in the in the bush?
>> That'd be Yahweh, right?
>> Yep. But specifically, it's the angel of
Yahweh.
>> So, that would be the Holy Spirit.
>> That would be Jesus before he took on
flesh. Oh, like I'm
>> No, no, it's good. I'm failing.
>> It's all right. Right. It says Christ
before he took on flesh.
>> Okay.
>> Okay. So, it says the angel of Yahweh
appeared to him right in the midst of
the bush. So,
>> he's in the bush, right? And though, so
Moses said, "Let me turn and see why
this bush hasn't burned up." And watch
what it says. Verse four, "And Yahweh
saw that he turned aside to look. So God
called to him from the midst of the bush
and said, "Moses, Moses." And he said,
"Here I am." So we see that the angel of
Yahweh is identified as Yahweh himself
while being disturbed from the father.
>> Okay. Okay. Okay. I got you.
>> So that's two. You have the father, you
have the angel of Yahweh who's also
Yahweh or the son Jesus Christ. Then
>> we go to 2 Samuel. Watch this. 2 Samuel
23. David says, "The spirit of Yahweh
spoke by me." Who spoke the spirit? The
spirit of Yahweh spoke by me.
>> It'd be the the Holy Spirit.
>> That's right. And his word was on my
tongue. The God of Israel said, "The
rock of Israel spoke to me." So you see,
the son, the spirit, and the father are
all identified as God. Yahweh, the God
of Israel, while the scripture is clear
that Yahweh is one, and there is no one
else who is Yahweh. You alone are
Yahweh.
>> Okay. So, cool. Cool. Cool.
>> Something happened to your audio.
>> Hello.
>> Yeah, you I can I can hear you, but
something happened. Say something.
>> Hold up. I'm about to take my AirPods
off.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
>> You hear me?
>> Yeah, that's better.
>> So, all right, that's cool. So, uh can
you clarify uh Jesus praying to the
father? Like, would that not imply
authority like over somebody else to bow
down?
>> The Bible says that Christ came to earth
and humbled himself, took on the form of
a servant. So it shouldn't surprise us
when we see Jesus in the flesh and he's
praying to the father and saying I came
to do the will of my father and stuff
like that. That's exactly what he came
to do. He came to be obedient and to
serve the father. Okay. So uh Jesus
taking on the role of a servant doesn't
take away from his deity, his divine
nature. Your role and and and how you
you know function has nothing to do with
your nature, your essence.
>> So would that even fall into the
character of God though?
>> Yeah, why not? You have you you have you
have throughout the scripture is showing
that if God is multi-personal one of one
of the other persons can serve the other
and humble himself to the other but it
doesn't take away from his own deity
doesn't take away from his own divine
nature right he can take the humble form
of a servant
>> for that for that uh no man listen um I
got to go I was I was smiling a lot I'm
not trying to like I wasn't trying to be
disrespectful it was just like I really
didn't think I was going to get in so I
appreciate that I uh you seem like a
very smart guy. I see your clips. Good
job, bro. Uh
>> thanks, man.
>> We disagree. We might not disagree.
>> I just want to get my knowledge up, bro.
All
>> aspect. Keep keep watching and keep
asking questions, man. All right.
>> Thumbs up. I'm about to show this to my
friends if that's okay with you. You
want a thumbs up or no?
>> Yeah, we good. Go ahead, bro. Take care,
man.